[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis une lesbienne blanche de 58 ans
alors si je vous dis ça c'est parce que
d'une part c'est politique
ça me permet d'avoir un rapport située à
la ville dans la société ça me permet
d'observer les systèmes de domination en
tant que lesbienne et puis en tant que
blanche ça me permet aussi parfois de ne
pas les voir d'avoir des privilèges que
je ne mesure pas et en définitive je
veux surtout vous dire que je suis
finalement comme chacune et chacun
d'entre vous ici quelqu'un de complexe
avec une identité qui se forge qui se
défait qui se refait et que c'est cette
richesse là je pense nous devons mettre
à contribution dans la création de la
ville mais seulement c'est assez
compliqué parce qu'on nous ramène
toujours à cette dualité arnal et femmes
des hommes et il est très difficile de
sortir de cet élément là dans un univers
assez hétérosexuels moi même en tant que
lesbienne on m'a souvent ramené à cette
dualité on me demande de choisir mon
camp
on me dit par exemple ben oui mais alors
si t'es pas une fille tu es un garçon
donc tu es un garçon manqué et on voit
bien que je passe d'une catégorie à
l'autre mais en même temps pas tout à
fait puisque le garçon est manquée 1
ce que veut dire qu'en plus quand on
transgresse la dire qu'on passe d'une
catégorie pour aller dans la catégorie
dominante
on peut pas tout à fait adhérer on voit
que c'est pas si simple
alors cette dualité quand j'ai cofondé
genre et ville avec l'urbaniste parce
qu'à de la palud ça a été un moment on
s'est dit cette chose là il faut qu'on
adresse
il faut qu'on il faut qu'on s'en sert il
faut qu'on voie comment démontrent les
choses parce que clairement c'est un
obstacle c'est caissons étanches nous
interdisent de voir des articulations
plus fine de la ville et des
articulations sociétal plus fine aussi
qu'est ce qui se passe en fait dans la
ville on est dans un système qu'on
qualifie d'hégémonie masculine
l'hégémonie masculine qu'est-ce que ça
c'est une idéologie
cette idéologie elle fait que l'on
vénère une certaine un certain idéal
masculin auquel l'ensemble des hommes
doivent se conformer et que par ailleurs
ce système là créer une forme de
soumission des femmes aux hommes
alors ça c'est pas construit par hasard
tout ça on a bien sûr hors des siècles
d'histoire derrière nous on peut dire
qu'il ya un moment où les choses se sont
un peu figé cristallisé c'est le 18 et
19ème siècles au 18e ou 19e siècle s'est
installée l'ordre bourgeois dans un
contexte de révolution industrielle et
cet ordre bourgeois il avait besoin de
créer des codes des normes pour rendre
la population productive en quelque
sorte
et à ce moment là on a vu que on a deux
sphères qui se sont créés la sphère
privée et la sphère publique aux hommes
la sphère publique et le pouvoir et aux
femmes la sphère privée avec un certain
pouvoir aussi qui est de tenir l'ordre
social
mais en même temps quand même sous le
contrôle du pater familias parce qu'il
faut pas rigoler ça reste quand même un
système de domination
parallèlement en ville on voit se
développer tout le travail de ce man
c'est l'avènement d'une forme de ville
guerrière haussmann sous prétexte
d'embellir la ville et dans un contexte
d'hygiénisme aussi à créer la ville
militaire c'est un espace défendable 1
où on doit pouvoir nettoyer les rues
facilement et à ce moment là on se rend
compte que les femmes disparaissent de
l'espace public
les femmes bourgeoises parce qu'il ne
faut pas qu'elle se frotte au petit
peuple et non plus qu'elle soit pollué
par les mauvaises idées aussi peut-être
et puis les femmes du peuple aussi les
commerçantes où les artisanes qui
travaille aussi la journée mais le soir
vont rentrer et s'occuper des tâches
invisible domestique et aussi de
contrôler des maris donc on voit qu'à ce
moment là quelque chose se forment là
parallèlement sous un os mal se décline
aussi une certaine forme de loisir
organisé
on va avoir les couples légitimes
qui est le dimanche vont aller sur les
grands boulevards bras dessus bras
dessous montrer leur pouvoir et toute
personne et notamment les femmes qui se
promène seul dans l'espace public vont
voir leur corps sexualisé c'est un
moment on voit que une femme seule est
forcément une femme de petite vertu
et elle va être jugé sur son corps alors
qu'est ce que ça nous dit ça c'est que
ces critères là on les retrouve encore
aujourd'hui dire qu'on va retrouver des
femmes très sexualisée on en a parlé
aujourd'hui on voit que ces questions de
harcèlement qui s'était relève bien de
toute cette positionne ce positionnement
du corps sexualité des femmes et au
niveau urbain
on se retrouve aussi après avoir vécu
donc la ville militaire haussmannienne
puis ensuite la ville fonctionnelle au
xxème siècle à une vie d'aujourd'hui qui
est presque sûr fonctionnalisés avec une
ville aussi sûre sécurisée une ville
dans laquelle les espaces publics se
restreignent auprès au profit des
espaces privés avec des grilles des
grillages des codes des caméras et tout
ça finalement est-ce que ça produit de
la sécurité c'est pas si sûr je rentre
d'un périple en europe ou qui m'a fait
aller dans une même semaine deux nappes
à vienne on sera très intéressant
d'abord parce que c'est vrai que sur le
plan thermique et un certain choc mais
surtout il y avait un choc culturel et
le choc culturel c'est que quand on va à
naples on vous dira la à naples mais
c'est une ville extrêmement dangereuse
c'est une ville qui est sale est dans le
c'est aussi un coupe gorge etc et on se
rend compte que les
que finalement fin nappe c'est une ville
que j'aime beaucoup parce que il ya une
sorte de négociation permanente qui se
joue dans cette ville alors qu'est-ce
qui qu'est ce qui se passe d'un app par
exemple si vous voulez traverser la rue
vous rendez compte que personne ne
respecte les feux et si vous voulez
franchir cet espace est bien il faut
s'élancer et vous rendez compte que les
voitures s'arrêtent elles ralentissent
et au fil du temps se rend compte que il
se passe un ballet harmonieux finalement
où les voitures passent tourner les
voitures s'arrêtent les passes les
passants franchise l'espace des scooters
arrive et c'est à vienne
c'est exactement l'inversé qui se passe
à vienne vous arrivez alors c'est une
ville belle c'est la ville du ballet
céder la valse mais c'est pas tout à
fait le même ballet c'est à dire qu'on
est dans une ville bourgeoise qui est
propre qui est carré est aussi très
normative c'est à dire que si vous
traversez en dehors des clous vous
allait être verbalisé
et qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là
c'est que au moment où le feu passe au
vert par exemple les voitures accélèrent
de façon extrêmement vive ce passage-là
de d'accélération mois va créer beaucoup
d'angoissé en fait et je me suis dit
tiens c'est marrant parce que finalement
à naples on m'a parlé de chaos et je me
suis sentie finalement très en sécurité
j'avais un sentiment de sécurité je
n'avais pas l'impression que quelque
chose pouvait m'arriver est à vienne
quitter la ville ordonnance et je suis
dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
cette ville est angoissante et j'étais
finalement pas si bien donc ça ça nous
dit quelque chose en fait sur les idées
reçues qu'on peut avoir sur ce qu'est
l'ordre ou ce qui n'est pas l'ordre mais
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que le
pouvoir n'aime pas le chaos le pouvoir
et le pouvoir masculin veux pouvoir
regarder les espaces et veut pouvoir les
contrôler alors comment sortir de ça la
théoricienne monique wittig nous a donné
une solution en l'occurrence elle nous
dit les lesbiennes ne sont pas des
femmes
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'elle imagine ou en tout cas elle a
théorisé le fait que
le système hétérosexuels binaire
dominant créé en fait un système d'
esclavage isation des femmes et que pour
sortir de ce système d'esclavagé isation
c'était extrêmement compliqué c'est à
dire qu' il fallait soit négocié pied à
pied la sortie de ce système soit être
définitive
je crois que la leçon d'être des
fugitive est intéressante et quand on
l'appliqué à la ville c'est aussi un
point qui peut être une autre façon de
penser des choses se sortir du cadre
sortir des codes que l'on connaît déjà
le travail que nous nous cherchons à
mener par exemple à jean rey ville c'est
d'articuler ça on se rend compte que une
autre ville est possible c'est une ville
qui pourrait s'organiser autour de deux
valeurs que je qualifierais du sensible
et de l'agilité alors le sensible pas au
sens sensibles rien mais bien au sens
multisensorielle c'est à dire de pouvoir
récupérer les espaces de pouvoir les
vivre
le pouvoir veut dire tiens je vais
m'asseoir parce qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui je suis détendu
c'est je suis dans un sentiment de
flânerie pouvoir commencer à goûter
l'espace à pouvoir écouter à retrouver
les parfums est une ville agi légalement
parce que c'est une ville qui doit
pouvoir être en mutation permanente qui
doit pouvoir se transformer qu'il va
pouvoir permettre des frottements qui
doit permettre aussi de se renouveler en
permanence
donc c'est une ville qui doit pouvoir
être en mutation une forme de
métamorphose une forme d'hybridation et
qui doit pouvoir vous amener aussi à une
autre façon de fonctionner ensemble
alors pour illustrer sa j'ai envie de
dire que cette vie parfois il existe
déjà un peu il y a par exemple à paris
ce pour celles et ceux qui sont
parisiens un espace il s'appelle la
villette où on peut retrouver selon les
temporalités des gens très différents
alors on a des grandes pelouse on a le
canal de l'ourcq on a aussi des petits
cheminement il ya toutes sortes de
choses qui s'y passe et si on y va le
matin là évidemment on va trouver les
joueurs de foot très nombreux sur
l'ensemble des terrains qui posent leurs
petits plots pour jouer qui prennent
l'espace
et puis quand on va vers midi on va voir
les couples qui commence à manger des
familles et puis l'après midi on va voir
encore d'autres personnes et en fait
toute une myriade finalement d'identité
c'est aussi un lieu avec une grande
mixité sociale
on est très proches d'aubervilliers donc
on va pouvoir trouver des personnes qui
sont de toutes cultures et qui vont se
retrouver dans cet espace et le vivre
largement faire de la musique jouer et
c'est pas plus tard que dimanche dernier
s'est passé un truc assez marrant c'est
que je suis arrivé pour faire mon
jogging comme d'habitude et puis comme
il y avait les hommes qui jouait je me
suis dit tiens je vais travailler un peu
j'ai sorti mon appareil photo pour faire
quelques photos des hommes qui étaient
en train de jouer au foot
et puis j'ai entendu une musique monte
et là je vous ai tiens c'est marrant
alors j'ai dû faire un grand tour parce
que savait que les hommes prennent
énormément d'espacé on dit que les
hommes occupent l'espace --en
l'occurrence là ils avaient largement
occupé donc j'ai fait le tour et je suis
arrivé sous l'auvent de la villette et
là il y avait en fait le choeur de
l'opéra de paris qui atteindrait qui
était en train de répéter alors je vous
le donne en mille c'était le choeur des
esclaves de nabucco et qui était chantée
par des femmes
alors là c'est un peu surprenant parce
que d'un côté on avait là quelque part
de une représentation assez caricatural
de ceux du kwh agco 2010 de my heart est
en fait ces terres d'une forme de
dualité on avait les hommes qui jouent
au foot et des femmes qui chantent et
qui plus est le choeur des esclaves et
mes surfaces de façon assez surprenante
il s'est passé quelque chose assez
extraordinaire c'est que pendant que ce
choeur est en train de jouer chanter et
que par ailleurs les hommes jouer au
foot à côté moi j'ai senti une sorte de
l'hybridation qui se passe est une très
grande émotion et monte le chant de la
musique du choeur des esclaves enrobant
les joueurs de foot et créant une forme
de poésie la même manière les
percussions le ballon les bruits il
écrit rentrait comme une forme de rap
sur le champ de nabucco il y avait une
sorte de de rythme comme ça qu'ils
montaient et cette poésie me vraiment
donner la chair de poule
et quelque part s'il y avait un message
que je voulais passer aujourd'hui c'est
que cette poésie là il faut qu'on arrive
à retrouver et cette poésie on peut la
produire ensemble
enfin c'est comme j'ai commencé tout à
l'heure aux dix ans nous étions une
grande diversité dans cette pièce et
avec une grande forme de d'identité je
pense que nous pouvons comme ce
moment-là nous hybride est créé un
moment un petit peu magique et retrouver
cette poésie
alors ensemble hybride on ou l'hybride
et vous et surtout hybride et vous avec
plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]